hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor before we get started today i
want to tell you that you can find a pdf
of the final board with all of the
blanks filled in
and all of the study notes added if you
look in the description there's going to
be a url that will take you to
a drive where you can freely access all
of the different board notes from my
study videos so check that out and
remember to subscribe to biology
professor
now let's get on to today's topic
and that is regarding the pathogenesis
of
atherosclerosis so atherosclerosis
messed that one up
atherosclerosis it's a hard one to say
i'm going to be talking about
all of the different
parts of how it comes about focusing on
some of the things you see up here in
the title so ldl oxidation macrophage
scavenger receptors foam cells the
formation of the plaques and so on
so
on the left hand side over here
i'll be filling in these blanks as we go
through and i'll be showing you kind of
where in this process we are as we go so
let's get started
so first let's talk about this hard work
that even i started to say
atherosclerosis what does this mean
this is when you get
lipid
based plaques
that cause arteries
to narrow and harden so basically
something like that right there
so going on to the
pathogenesis uh
we're going to
look at
all these different steps so let's just
start with the first one we've got
arterial endothelial cells
become
damaged
and so right here we're looking at this
you know within an artery we've got the
lumen this is where like the red blood
cells are we've also got some ldl and
some monocytes and there's some kind of
damage done
to this endothelial layer
and so there are numerous causes for
this
hypercholesterolemia or too much
cholesterol
sort of chronically in the blood can
cause it so can hyperglycemia
chronically high blood sugar smoking
hypertension that's the high blood
pressure these are all different things
that can cause
damage and then dysfunction
to this layer of endothelial cells
now when this damage happened
these cells where the damage has
occurred can also start releasing free
radicals basically like reactive oxygen
species
remember that reactive oxygen species
includes free radicals and also some
other types of things like you know
peroxides and so on
so the reactive oxygen species get
produced
because of that damage or following that
damage
then
this damage means that the arterial
walls become more permeable to ldl
remember that's low density lipoprotein
this is a specific way in which
cholesterol
is moved through the body and so we've
got our ldl particles i've drawn them
here in green
going through the bloodstream
and so this damage
makes the arterial walls more permeable
to ldl allowing the ldl
to actually go
you know across the endothelium into the
tissue on the other side of the
endothelial layer and this tissue is
called the tunica entoma so you get ldl
increasing
in concentration because of the damage
to the endothelial
cells then you've got adhesions on the
damaged endothelial cells capture
monocytes
so i could i'm going to kind of draw
basically some like a receptor right
there you've got an adhesion protein
that will capture a circulating monocyte
remember that a monocyte is a type of
white blood cell it's part of the immune
system so the receptor the adhesion and
underlying that right there
adhesions on the damaged endothelial
cells will capture the monocytes
and this will
uh increase
the
their sort of movement their migration
into the tunica
entoma
now when they enter when the monocytes
enter the tissue the tunica intima
they are then going to develop in
something called macrophages so
monocytes are the ones circulating in
the blood and then when they enter a
specific tissue
they are stimulated to develop into
macrophages so we've got the monocyte
moves in and now it's a macrophage
and they are also going to be producing
free radicals so some of these reactive
oxygen species so they were already we
already had reactive oxygen species free
radicals being produced by the damaged
endothelial cells and now they're being
produced by these macrophages as well
now these free radicals that are being
produced they will
oxidize
ldl
so right here
when the ldl is oxidized
by these free radicals that are coming
either from the damaged endothelial
cells
or from the macrophages
i started drawing the oxidized ldl in
red so the concentration of oxidized ldl
is also increasing in the tunica entity
and this has the unfortunate side
effects of attracting even more
monocytes
um basically you've got even more
monocytes that because of the increase
in oxidized ldl here you've got even
more monocytes that are going to come
right down here let me grab my purple
marker
and i'll draw another of these
uh
macrophages
so this is a kind of
basically positive feedback loop
um we might also call it a vicious cycle
right this is not the kind of positive
feedback loop you want to happen
remember that positive feedback loop
just means that the signal basically
keeps moving further and further away
from homeostasis so there's these these
signals and you have more and more and
more
activity and problems cropping up
i also want to mention just that the
movement of the monocytes into the
tissue i'm going to put this in
parentheses here
is through
a
a process called diapedesis that's just
the process through which they kind of
flatten
and move through the small space to get
into the tissues
the signaling
that encourages this behavior is the
chemokine signaling so basically the
more you have
oxidized ldl down here the more you have
macrophages
secreting chemokines the more you have
more monocytes that are going to be
coming in and turning into macrophages
and secreting more chemokines
to attract more to attract more
monocytes and so that's that positive
feedback loop now these macrophages once
they get down here into the tunica
intima
i'm going to
draw some receptors on this new one here
they've got these receptors that i've
drawn in black here
these receptors
are called macrophage scavenger
receptors
and they allow the macrophages to engulf
the oxidized ldl now these are not
normal ldl receptors these are
specifically for the oxidized ldl
and so they're called the macrophage
scavenger receptors and what you end up
getting is that these macrophages they
engulf so much of this oxidized ldl
that they really increase in size and
they start to have a foamy appearance
and we call these
foam cells because of that foamy
appearance
and so
that is what the macrophages
turn into
they engulf the oxidized ldls using
their scavenger receptors
and that turns them into bone cells
another name for the foam cells is lipid
laden macrophages sometimes you you hear
that term instead
now ultimately
you get a lot of foam cells lots and
lots of foam cells it's because so many
monocytes have crossed over into the
tunica enzyma
and they have engulfed so much of this
oxidized ldl you've got lots and lots of
foam cells so they're building up
excuse me and they're also bursting so
just
just you know spewing their guts out
basically um into the tissue
and so this build up
and bursting
of the foam cells
increases
that reactive
oxygen species
remember that's the ros
put that in parentheses right here ros
increases the reactive oxygen species
that are floating around here and what
does that do that just oxidizes even
more ldl okay so it's just this
really
um unfortunate and damaging positive
feedback loop
that also redu that also
results in other inflammatory particles
coming in
it also stimulates migration
and
proliferation
of
smooth muscle cells
and where are these coming from
underneath the tunica entomo remember
you've got the lumen out here there's
the endothelium this is all happening in
the tuna intima and then in another
layer below that you've got something
called the tunica media
and you've got some smooth muscle cells
there
and they can actually migrate up into
the tunica intima and then proliferate
there to make more of themselves divide
and reproduce and the result
of all of these steps
of all of that buildup and breakdown of
foam cells the the migration and
proliferation of the smooth muscle cells
is you go from what was originally a
healthy artery
that sustained some kind of damage
and through the activity of those foam
cells and the smooth muscle cells moving
in you get the production of a plaque
and the plaque itself
can then cause other issues you know it
can it can form a blood clot
embolism heart attack stroke and so on
all of these different
kinds of
um health issues can be
caused you know they start off as
plaques just like that one
and then of course i also
don't want to forget to mention the
inflammation that there's lots of
inflammation in this process as well
which can have other systemic types of
symptoms
before we conclude i want to remind you
that i've got some other study videos on
related topics you know we've talked a
lot about
macrophages
in this video macrophages are really
known for phagocytosis so if you want to
learn about the steps of phagocytosis
i've got a video on that and then if you
want to learn how pathogens can actually
evade macrophages some of them even
being able to replicate in macrophages
which would normally kill them and
instead they're replicating inside then
i've got another video on that process
as well so check those out remember to
hit subscribe and thank you very much
for watching biology professor don't
forget that you can grab a pdf of the
board notes at the link below and i'll
see you next time bye